hello i wanted to talk seriously and
honestly for a moment
about my thoughts on what's been going
on for the past couple months
and hopefully you you can get a better
understanding of
my perspective i think it's time to end
the subscribe to pewdiepie movement or
me
it's something that started off as a way
to keep me as the number one
most subscribed channel on youtube and
seeing so many people come to my support
other creators as well has been
incredibly humbling to me
it's really really meant a lot it's
something i never thought i would
experience and it's something i thought
would last also for maybe
just a couple of days or maybe a week
but here we are
it's been six to seven months now and
it's been a crazy journey
at first it started off with people
doing really positive and fun things to
get attention
through subscribe to pewdiepie but
something i learned and
i think hopefully it's something people
can understand is when you have
90 million people riled up about
something you're bound to get a few
degenerates
and it started off with someone spray
painting
sub to pewdiepie on a world war ii
memorial and just so disgusting
so disappointing to have my name and
community uh
dragged into that i addressed it on
twitter i disavowed it
we saw that it got removed and and
donated to the park
hoped that that was gonna be it i didn't
want hateful acts to
overpower all these amazing things that
people were doing all these cool and
positive things
but then something happened that i don't
think
anyone would have predicted the
christchurch
shooter said subscribe to pewdiepie out
of the the respect for
the families and victims involved i
chose not to address it any further than
on twitter where i disavowed the actions
taken that day and i
gave my sincerest condolences to
everyone affected to have my name
associated
with something so unspeakably vile has
affected me in more ways than i let
shown i just didn't want to address it
right away
and i didn't want to give the terrorist
any more attention
i didn't want to make it about me
because i i don't think it has anything
to do with me to put it plainly i didn't
want hate to win
but it's clear to me now the sub
subscribe
to pewdiepie movement should have ended
then lastly my feelings around the
subscribe to pewdiepie thing would not
be complete without mentioning t-series
uh i made two diss tracks that were made
in fun
ironic jess they were not meant to be
taken seriously
and now high court in india demands that
they're gonna be blocked
and removed this was all made to be fun
but it's clearly not fun anymore
it's clearly gone too far and out of
respect for that i'm gonna
keep the videos blocked on a similar
note some people in some media
has made this sub to pewdiepie thing
about
race or about politics or nationality
and i don't agree with that at all and i
want that to stop
this negative rhetoric is something i
don't agree with at all and i want that
to stop and to make it perfectly clear
no i'm not racist i don't support any
form of
racist comments or hate towards anyone
finally
i don't want hitting 100 million
subscribers to be about
beating another channel i think what
we've accomplished is so much more than
that
and i just want to say i feel incredibly
lucky to have such an amazing group of
people supporting me
i think i can say that because i know
them better than anyone i
ironically i'm so proud of this
community and this movement started out
of love and support
so let's end it with that i hope that
you understand my perspective
and i ask you kindly to accept it thank
you for listening
that's all bye